[Music]
well we got a great treat today I've got
a one of my colleagues from our geology
and geophysics department professor
Kanani Lee kanani's an experimental
geophysicist she did her undergraduate
degree in physics at the University of
San Francisco and her PhD at Berkeley
she went on beekeeping in a postdoc at
Caltech was at New Mexico State for a
little while and has been on the Yale
faculty since 2008
and does all sorts of cool stuff right
so you know so if you guys you know do
well right get yourselves admitted to
Yale you know you might be able to work
in kanani's lab or you know work in one
of the field labs in G&G they just do
all sorts of neat physics and chemistry
and geology also right so join me in
welcoming professor at Kanaly hi guys
can you hear me can you hear me now okay
can you hear me now right so I was told
that I should give you a like a brief
little like how did I get into science
so you heard my bio right I was a
physics undergrad I did my PhD in
geophysics and then about almost 10
years ago I came here but why did I come
here where you know how did I get here
and so I just want to give you a little
bit more of a background I was actually
born and raised in Hawaii and so for
those of you who know Hawaii you might
say well gosh it's pretty obvious then
why you went into geology after all you
live on a volcanic island in the middle
of the ocean and and I would love to say
that that's absolutely the truth and why
I came to why I turn into geo and became
a geologist but it's actually not I I
studied physics as an undergrad
and at a very young age I wanted to be a
physicist now you don't know what that
actually meant for those of you who are
in the audience who are old enough to
remember the television program MacGyver
does anybody remember that TV program so
it was on when I was a kid and I would
watch it with my dad and I thought man
this guy MacGyver he is amazing what a
smart person this you know this person
is so the background is this MacGyver
character could basically get himself
out of any you know trouble or you know
with basically as you know Swiss Army
knife and some duct tape of course it
was a television show and so it was very
Hollywood but I was taken by it and I
asked my I asked my dad I said so how
does how does MacGyver become so smart
he says oh well you got to take physics
and so I was sold and so I took physics
turns out physics and chemistry all
these things are very important in earth
science and learning about the earth and
so I took my physics background and I
decided to apply it to the earth after
all this is where we live and there's so
many fascinating things that we observe
that we are part of that I didn't
understand at the time and there's still
a lot of things that we as our
scientists are still trying to figure
out and so this is like a it's an
exciting way to you know get your
science in and learn about what's going
on inside the planet and so my research
in my research I'm an experimentalist
and so what I do is I try to recreate
the conditions inside of our planet and
other planets and so a little a little
later on during this talk I'll show you
the kind of tools that we use and and
tell you a little bit about it but first
let's figure out what's going up going
on inside the inside of the earth okay
so that's today's that's the the theme
of today's today's little talk here is
we're going to try to figure out the
earth from the inside out because what I
try to do
is recreate the conditions inside the
planet and let's see if we can if that
can if we can learn anything about what
is going on on the outside I also want
to make a plug so before you guys leave
today my I'm actually my family is here
so my husband and my two boys are
sitting up on the top row there and so
my husband and I actually wrote a couple
of comic comic books
on earth science okay so before you
leave today please grab a copy taking
home with you you can learn more about
it one is on plate tectonics which we'll
learn a lot about today and the other
one is talks about the moon so take that
it they were actually they were actually
funded by the National Science
Foundation as part of a larger grant
that I put together and they were made
specifically to be used in the middle
schools here in New Haven and so it uses
the the you know the the rubrics of what
of what is is taught in the seventh and
eighth grade here in New Haven
so it's geared towards that but I've had
they've been out for a few years now
I've had you know children as young as
my own up to college students use it so
it is meant for for everyone okay
so the big question there are lots of
questions but the big question the
overarching question that I try to
answer with my research is this right
how does the earth work and how has it
evolved and work here is really I mean
we could use it in many different ways
but you know how does it do what it's
doing right so here's what what the
inside of the earth just what we think
it basically looks like okay and we have
to infer what it looks like based on
what we see on the outside okay
and then also some things that we can do
in the lab on the inside okay so what do
we what are some observations that we
see
here on earth anybody want to garner
some guesses yeah we see volcanoes right
in the back yeah we see plants and
animals we see life including our own
yeah buildings we still what are those
buildings made out of rocks that's right
yeah cement right natural resources like
what kind of natural resources water
lots of water yeah very very important
actually teach a lecture here on campus
all about water but we won't go much
into that today
trenches and mountain is that what you
said oh yeah
trenches good yes earthquakes all right
so we got so the first answer the day
was volcanoes that's the last answer of
the day was was earthquakes perfect so
you said everything that the two things
that I was I was mainly looking for but
the other things that we've talked about
is are very important right as far as we
know at least I not in our own solar
system right life is is obviously here
on earth but the the complexity of life
is not found anywhere else in our solar
system we're looking okay but we're it's
quite unique and there are lots of
reasons why that is okay if anybody's
interested in that they can come and
talk to me afterwards well we're gonna
focus on the inside okay so volcanoes
and earthquakes well the other things
that we see are magnetic field so
anybody that use the compass or been on
you know or know what a compasses been
on a plane would have a GPS and in the
well I guess the GPS doesn't really use
a compass but yeah we've all used
compasses or we know what it what it
what it's all about right it's tells us
where the North Pole is tells us to
which direction is north and the reason
why we have we can use a compass is
because we have a magnetic field that is
produced in the center of the planet in
a molten
in the molten part of the iron core and
on the very inside of that core is a
solid iron now looks very different from
a magnet that you might find on your
refrigerator but the shape of it looks
very similar okay it has a north and a
South Pole we'll get to that in a little
bit but all these cool observations that
we see here on the surface okay that
we've come to just take for granted
right well the earth hasn't always
looked this way right actually in fact
the earth was very different some four
and a half plus billion years ago okay
so this is an artist's impression of
what an early Earth would have looked
like right before the moon-forming
impact or right as the moon-forming
impact so this is this is a growing
earth notice it's got a bunch of spots
all over it those are impact craters so
we're thought that the planet and all
the planets were born this way okay may
built up from smaller objects like
meteorites and so they got very very
large to have their own gravitational
pull so that they could attract other
objects like this one which is which is
probably about the size of Mars okay
hitting or impacting this proto earth so
this kind of impact would have been very
very hot okay very very violent okay so
you would have been extremely hot the
planet was likely mostly molten or at
least the rocky part of it is and it
would have looked nothing like it does
today
so the question then becomes how do we
go from this really hot molten
pockmarked surface to something that
looks more like this now this is just a
cartoon - it's much more complicated
than this but you know we've got cotton
in song continents and oceans right
inside so we have the crust that's where
we live that's where the oceans are but
beneath that we have this vast region
called the mantle
this is the rocky part of the planet and
it's solid okay
pretty much ninety-nine point you know
99.9 percent of it is solid okay it's
not molten even though our lavas and our
Magma's come from there okay it's mostly
solid beneath that then we have that
core where the magnetic field is made
this is iron this is basically rock in
the screen and then on the top here is
the crust so we call this layering the
word is called differentiation so it's
been it's been the the layers in the
planet have been stratified that way
because or it went from this to looking
something like this so fully molten to
basically mostly solid except for this
region here with a in the in the core
where the magnetic field is being made
okay so how does that happen so a couple
of things that we know about the earth
we know its mass we know how its extent
and how you know how big it is what its
volume is but it's but it's often since
since we live here on the surface we
lived here you know on top of the crust
it's hard to kind of imagine the size
right you know how deep it is and how
big it actually is okay well what I want
to get to you is that the this mantle
part okay
it's about two-thirds of the mass of the
planet and it's about it's more than 80%
of the volume okay and this is where
most of my research has done so it's in
the in the vast majority of the planet
is this rocky solid rocky part and this
is where most of the stuff is happening
that is causing those earthquakes and is
causing those volcanoes that we see
alright that we observe or what we feel
the core is the basically the remainder
of it and the crust doesn't even come up
on this list in terms of the amount of
mass or
the amount of volume it's such a small
fraction of it it's just very very very
very thin layer even though we've got
really large mountains and so forth in
comparison to the rest of the volume to
the rest of the mass of the planet
it's very insignificant so how do we
notice about the earth what do we what
you know I can show these pictures but
how do we really know what's going on so
there are four sub disciplines that
study the inside of the planet so we
have seismology so this is a study of
sound waves that travel through the
planet and the saw those sound waves are
generally produced by earthquakes okay
so we have an earthquake here and those
sound waves travel through the planet
and picked up by a seismometer okay or
if you don't have a seismometer and
you've ever felt an earthquake anybody
actually ever felt an earthquake
where'd you feel they feel your
earthquake who could have been a big one
yeah funny no I would normally hear it
well some of the other places where
words some other earthquakes have been
felt Japan Oh also potential for very
large one yes yeah okay good did you see
the volcanoes there too oh wow so these
are actually really quite active places
anybody feel though that we had a small
earthquake here in Connecticut not far
not too long ago you remember feeling it
yeah I actually didn't feel it but but
um but it but it did register it did
register an if you were close enough you
would have been able to see it I'm sorry
No okay I didn't hear it okay so um so
these earthquakes so we found this so
there's you know Japan Nicaragua here in
Connecticut and I forget what the India
India right
so for except for the except for the the
one here in Connecticut those other ones
oh and there was one in Hawaii too so
except for the Hawaii one and the and
the one in Connecticut those earthquakes
were produced because you basically a to
play it's kind of jamming into each
other and then one has got to go
underneath okay so these are subduction
related kinds of earthquakes
okay these tend to be make the really
large earthquakes okay anyway so we have
so we have earthquakes and those sound
waves are gonna travel through the
planet so that's one way we can tell
about the earth the other thing we can
tell is like all right well we have
samples of what's coming out of the
earth right we have lavas okay actually
I have here so this I'm proud to say I
actually picked up myself I'm not a
field geologist I work in a lab so often
when people say oh you're a geologist
you can you know identify any rock I'm
not that kind of geologist but I did go
out into the field and I did pick this
one up so I found this one in Kilburn
hole which is a crater as a volcanic
crater in New Mexico's southern New
Mexico very near the Mexican border and
what it is so the black part of it is
actually a basalt okay is that word
familiar 21 basalt yeah do you know why
it's cooler or why is it familiar to you
yeah and where do you normally find
basalt you know the base of a volcano
okay
Hawaii is a good place to find basalt
things basically where you come from
from some depth some pretty deep but
what you'll notice about this basalt is
it's it's black okay it's a very dark
color and this is this is typical
of assault now that's not the cool part
ok the cool part what makes this
particularly is that there's all these
little green and brown minerals that are
kind of interspersed within this basalt
okay and these pieces these are actually
pieces of the mantle that came from
about a hundred fifty kilometers depth
150 kilometers anybody know how far that
is in miles roughly it's about a hundred
miles so it's like you driving here to
New York City ish kinda okay
that's how instead of going from here to
New York City imagine drilling down that
far okay so it's really far okay and the
thing is that we don't actually we this
wasn't drilled okay this came up with a
volcanic eruption and instead of looking
like everything else which is with the
black basalt that it would have come up
as as most of the rock would have this
came up intact and it's thought that
this would actually pull up from the
sides of the magma chamber okay and it
came up so quickly that even though it
was hot it didn't melt because it
happened so quickly okay and so now we
have a piece of the mantle that came
from 150 kilometers depth okay which is
kind of cool right now does anybody know
how deep we can actually drill into the
planet or how far people have drilled
into the planet you have any ideas yeah
howdy
a million kilometres will that be really
deep yeah no that does upon it's not
quite that deep and yet a few kilometers
right yeah so like if we want to just
cut it around about ten kilometers is is
the deepest than any of our drills have
ever gone okay and what happens after
that
how can we've been to haven't been able
to drill deeper just so no do you have a
question do you want to how come we
haven't drilled any deeper we can't find
it yeah it turns out that our drill bits
actually can't can't handle can't handle
the heat at those steps and they just
can't handle the rock they just stayed
they they're not strong enough okay so
the drill bits break and then we're
stuck so we can drill pretty deep and
there are efforts to do this but not
nearly as deep as we can just naturally
that just that come up sometimes
question here oh you can make a diamond
trip and they have and it's still not
hard enough
and in fact okay so I actually use
diamonds in my research okay and what do
we know about diamonds right what do you
hear about diamonds hardest material
diamonds are forever right
I can easily say and I and I've lost
track counting but I've easily at least
broken at least a hundred diamonds in my
in the course of my time doing what I do
so so unfortunately even a diamond tip
drill bit isn't gonna is it hasn't been
able to to go deeper than that
say again no actually obsidian is even
is even is even weaker
yeah if Citian is is a glass um it and
and it is is is actually a glass it's a
it's a very dark glass and it would be
much weaker than the than the diamond
that's right
it becomes really really hot and and and
that's why they can't it when when
things get hot when these metal or even
diamond drill bits get get hot they get
weak and so they're unable to to drill
any further and remember this so so
actually did I even mention that you
know how deep is it how deep is it to
get to the core from the surface down to
the core is about 6,400 kilometers okay
which is really deep and if we can only
go about 10 kilometers we're nowhere
near the mantle and and the core for
that matter we're so far away okay so
anyway so we have seismology we have
samples from the earth we also have
samples of meteorites which is what we
think that the planet was made up of we
have models that look at how material
moves so geo dynamics and then finally
we have mineral physics so mineral
physics is is my part of the of this
puzzle and trying to understand what's
going on inside the planet okay all
right so uh let's go on so that's
mineral physics alright so here is a map
of recent earthquakes and volcanic
eruptions okay so in the the little
black triangles are some volcanoes and
then in red are earthquakes so what do
you notice about this map yes
yeah so what so what about those where
you were they located they're located
and different cut they're located all
over right all over different countries
yeah hot climates hmm
what about up here is that hot yeah
Alaska here somebody's taken in our
science class we got the Ring of Fire
right okay so around here sort of just
going around the Pacific Ocean is what's
been called the Ring of Fire and it's
called the Ring of Fire is because one
many many volcanoes are around it right
and also earthquakes so for the most
part wherever you see a volcano
you also see earthquakes with a few
exceptions right like here but for the
most part if there are volcanoes there
you also get earthquakes right question
hmm okay yes so they're different kinds
of earthquakes and they're different
kinds of volcanoes absolutely so in the
envy where you have subduction so where
you have two plates coming together in
one sinks underneath you can get very
large earthquakes this is what happens
in Japan for instance now Japan also so
Japan here right here that here is Japan
lots of earthquakes and lots of
volcanoes okay so what happens when when
you have the the oceanic plate so the
Pacific Ocean plate here going
underneath the continental the Asian
continent okay what ends up happening is
this doesn't like to this doesn't like
it right I mean there's gonna be some
friction here the friction is part of
what is causing the earthquakes okay now
the other thing that's causing the the
volcanoes though is that as you get
these as you get these plates dipping
down or subducting underneath the other
one it's also dragging other stuff with
it okay after all it's part of the ocean
plate so other things that it's dragging
down there well okay so the oceans are
full of water right so what do you think
might be down on the ocean floor or the
kinds of rocks that are down on the
ocean floor
yes sand okay with salt yes there there
under lots of underwater volcanoes yep
rocks yeah yeah lots of rocks what about
some like um what happens when crabs die
lobsters or some you know some sea life
and they have they have hard shells okay
all right so those hard shells are
actually made out of there's some carbon
in there some water anyway so we get the
we get we get these hydrated and even
carbonated kinds of rocks and material
down there at the bottom of the ocean
and some of this stuff gets abducted as
the plate goes down with it and this
provides then things like water into the
Mansell and what happens when we when we
put things like water into the mantle
it actually week.the the minerals that
hold this water are weaker than the
minerals that don't have the water or
the carbon in them okay and by weaker
what that means then is that the
temperature that it takes to melt it is
much lower okay so it doesn't take as
much heat in order to in order to melt
these hydrated rocks and so that melted
rock becomes the lavas that feed those
volcanoes okay so where you have
subduction okay like here in Japan here
near Alaska here along the Central
America and down the coast of the South
America you have lots of volcanoes lots
of earthquakes okay in the middle here
so here we have Hawaii this is where I
grew up right lots of volcanoes and even
an earthquake that that was felled and
there are some earthquakes there but
mostly known for its volcanoes these
volcanoes though don't aren't coming
from aren't aren't generated the same
way okay
these volcanoes have basalt okay and
those those Magma's that are feeding
those lava those those uh magma chambers
and and then what comes out as lava are
thought to come from really deep inside
the planet perhaps even thousands of
kilometers okay
rather than these ones here that come
out at the at subduction zones those
ones come from more shallower depths
okay so like hundred kilometers instead
of thousands of kilometers
okay so hmm
let's look at these earthquakes I'm
gonna need a volunteer okay right here
perfect right in the front okay so so
earthquakes provides sound waves hiss
that go through the planet so I'm gonna
we're gonna we're gonna mimic that with
a slinky here right I'm gonna have you
hold one end okay
now why don't we put it on the on the
table here so what you stand on one end
there and okay perfect you just stay
there okay so hopefully you can mostly
see this all right so there are three
different kinds of three different kinds
of waves in the planet but see the two
most important for the interior of the
of the earth anterior interior of any
kind of body are called p-waves and
s-waves so a p-wave is a compressional
wave or a pressure wave that's what the
P stands for okay so I'm gonna give a
pressure wave here and that's gonna look
like this okay so you see as the as the
slinky is moving back and forth okay the
wave is going towards what's your name
it's going towards Julia and then it's
bouncing back and coming towards me okay
and and how fast it's moving back and
forth is dependent on how fast I'm
moving my hand okay but you can do this
and you'll see this sort of packet going
back and forth this is a P wave this is
the same way that you're hearing my
voice right now okay the air is moving
and it's vibrating your your ear your
eardrums
okay and it's moving like this and so
depending on how I'm talking it'll move
your eardrum either really quickly or
more slowly and then that is being
translated as sound into your into your
brain so also those are P waves now P
waves move the fastest in the earth
okay this moves really fast now the
other kind of way of important for the
inside of the earth are called s waves
or shear waves and shear waves now you
can step back
okay so shear waves move like this okay
so here is it so we can have a wave that
goes up and down we can have a wave that
goes side to side which may be a little
bit easier to see if you were looking
down this way okay and these waves move
slower than P waves okay but they move
sort of the motion this way is is okay
so when we when we propagate when we
move a P wave right we're going back and
forth right
but when removing a shear wave okay it's
sort of cutting the air in this case
okay
Thank You Juliet now what's what's
what's special about the differences in
these waves is how they can travel
through material okay so compressional
waves P waves can travel through air
right like like how you're hearing me it
can travel through things that are solid
and it can travel through things that
are liquid has no problems right you can
talk underwater and you can hear it it
may sound distorted but you can still
hear it now this is true of P waves S
waves though are unable to travel
through liquid and then this difference
makes it useful to tell what's going on
inside the planet okay alright so for
instance now this is a busy busy figure
okay but if we have an earthquake here
and this one here says earthquake
earthquake epicenter Northridge
California okay so there's a big
earthquake in Northridge California in
1994 I believe 1994 and lots of damage
and so forth mmm actually that kind of
earthquake was not produced like the
ones we talked about today that was
actually produced because of friction
this way
a strike-slip type of friction anyway
irregardless of how it was formed that
earthquake is going to send waves
through the planet and if we have layers
in the planet okay how the wave travels
through them is going to how fast they
travel through them is going to change
depending on what it's going through
right so when I'm talking underwater my
voice sounds differently than what I'm
talking in air and that's because the
speed at which my my voice is traveling
is different between the two so I
mentioned that this part here this outer
core was liquid which means your s waves
can't travel through it but your P waves
can okay so as we have a wave and these
are these are the paths that a wave
might follow they will start to turn
around depending on the rock that it's
going through and then it'll bounce off
on these surfaces where they're really
different where you have rock versus
metal okay and so you'll get these
changes in in its path okay depending on
what it's going through okay so if we
can get a if we if if we can say with
experiments be able to tell how fast a
wave travels through material we can
then tell you what kind of rock and what
kind of metal this has to be and so you
can put together models of how the
density and the velocities change as you
go deeper down into the planet so you'll
see here that all these little steps
here as we change in density so that the
planet gets denser as we go down deeper
and then they're just big step from here
on the mantle rocky side to the core
side you get an almost a factor of two
increase in the density and why is that
because we're going from a rock to a
metal we're going to iron which is very
dense a special
yet those pressures and temperatures get
a quick question yep
yep yeah so the volcano so the volcano
has the the lava that comes out of the
volcano had to be hot enough to melt the
rock now if it's hot enough to melt the
lava then why doesn't everything else
melt too right so there has to be a
change a different chemistry and that so
to lower the temperature that something
has to melt at we can add water right
that's one of the ways that that can be
done and so then that those those rocks
they have a little bit of water in them
will melt at a lower temperature and so
we could have melt there which is which
is where the lava the magma are from and
everything else would remain solid so
after all we don't have a lot of melt
presently today yes that's because
there's a lot there's a lot of
subduction going on and a lot of a lot
of there's just a lot of tectonic
activity right so where we had volcanoes
we also had earthquakes the opposite
isn't true I mean you know we have
earthquakes many many places where there
are earthquakes and there aren't any
volcanoes and that's because like in
California at least for this Northridge
earthquake that was shown on the earlier
that was caused because of friction this
way so just sliding okay so just sliding
that's next to each other rather than
dipping underneath each other so there
wasn't a chance for water to get into
the planet without so so the so we
weren't forming there aren't we weren't
forming any volcanoes that way there
okay there are mountain ranges okay but
those are produced because of all this
grinding that the rocks are doing okay
so let's move on as we were going
through so the other thing that that
these seismic waves can tell us about is
how these subducting plates so here in
blue and blue here are these subducting
plates so these are like
whether where you have one plate full of
water going down underneath the
continental plate okay so we can image
those plates and that's what's shown in
these blue these blue parts here okay so
you have subduction here subduction all
along the South America in Japan here
just above New Zealand where you have
these subduction going on okay so let's
look at those votes look at those
volcanic rocks okay so this is this is
similar to the to the rock that I that I
showed earlier so we have the basalt and
you've got this greenish part here
that's full of olivine which is which is
one of the main minerals are the most
abundant mineral in the upper part of
the mantle okay this is what basalt
looks like molten flowing in Hawaii okay
so when it's still molten and very hot
you see it's still yellow in red and
orange as it cools it'll form a black
crust okay which is which is the same
thing as as shown here so we have these
very dark rocks basalt now on the other
side of the spectrum the other kinds of
volcanism that we that we see here on
the planet are things like granite right
or what may be some of your countertops
are made of in your kitchens
so granite which in this case can what
can come in many many colors but it's
very white here and actually Mount
Rushmore is is is is been carved out of
granite here's another another granite
here so it's a little Pinker now these
two rocks are quite different they're
very different
this kind of granite would come out of
or these kind of lighter rocks would
tend to come out of volcanism that is
produced near subduction okay whereas
these basalts are produced much deeper
okay so these this is this is the kind
of lava that you'll find in in Hawaii
for instance
now if you keep so we have very dark
rocks we have lighter colored rocks
well what about meteorites so I said
meteorites are what are the building
blocks for the earth ok these are little
things that that are accreted together
in these big impact impacts that then
form the planet so yours just you're
just a few meteorites these have been
collected this is an iron meteorite and
as like the name would suggest it's
basically all iron iron nickel there
might be a few other other elements like
carbon or sulfur or silicon or maybe
even a little bit of oxygen but it's
basically all iron then we have
meteorites that are more stony ok and
then we have meteorites that are a mix
of iron and and and some minerals ok so
you can see like the little the green
and orange here too heavy so what's
different what's the what's the first
thing that you look at this that's
different as compared to the granite and
the basalt that we find on the surface
of the earth
what's the mate what's the main
difference that you see between these I
mean sure they're more kind of blackish
they are there they tend to be dark they
also tend to be shinier maybe yeah shiny
they've got a lot of metal in them they
have a lot of iron in them in comparison
to the rocks we find here at the surface
of the earth okay so this is puzzling
right like you find a meteorite if you
ever has sort of meteorites are mostly
found like in places where it's really
obvious like Antarctica or in the middle
of a desert so you see a black rock
sitting it on some ice or in the middle
of a desert it would be like what is
this thing doing here okay and so that's
like the first clue and then you pick it
up and it's really heavy it's really
heavy it's because there's a lot of
there's a lot of iron in those things
and that's fine because even though we
think this is what makes up the earth we
had to make a core right the core part
of the
of the planet is made up mostly of iron
and so where do the iron come from will
have to come from the meteorites and its
density its heaviness allowed it to sink
under gravity to the center of the
planet okay okay so we have some
composition we have the waves that
travel through the planet now let's go
to my part of it the mineral physics
part of it how do we combine those
things and and and take it further so we
have to run some experiments okay so I
have so I said I use I said earlier that
I use diamonds and I do and and you
might think okay so how so I'm so I can
produce all the pressures and all the
temperatures inside of our planet how
big do you think my diamonds are these
massive diamonds the diamonds themselves
are actually pretty small okay so about
quarter carat maybe quarter to a third
carat okay so so think of like I'm a
modest engagement ring size okay
and if you can see from the back which
you probably can't there are two of them
one on this side one on this side and
then so you can see them they're from
the side and so these are tough these
are small diamonds they're small they're
only a couple millimeters in height and
they're shaped like a brilliant cut
diamond more or less but what we've done
is cut off the tip here shaved down the
tip so there's a flat surface between
the tips of those diamonds and then we
can put a sample a rock piece of metal
water whatever you want in between those
two diamonds and then we can press them
together because diamonds are hard
they're strong and they're transparent
to many forms of light we can look at
our sample while it is under high
pressures okay so
um for instance so I take this I put my
sample in between I close it up okay and
if I were to just now stand on this
diamond cell the weight my force due to
just my mass my weight okay
would provide about ten Giga Pascal's of
pressure onto my sample now 10 Giga
Pascal's I don't expect anyone to really
fathom what that how much that is but
it's about or it's a hundred thousand
times the pressure that your ears are
feeling right now and it would
correspond to rough to roughly about 300
kilometers depth
okay so deeper than any rocks that we
have samples of okay just with my
bodyweight I can produce that okay you
said I could do all the pressures in the
in the earth right okay so let's let's
look at us another way so here's about
an elephant elephant big right largest
largest living land animal imagine
putting this elephant in a stiletto heel
okay hard to imagine yes okay five now
if I put this if I put this elephant in
a cell it'll heal so a stiletto heel
that the the area of the heel part his
only it's about this big okay roughly
and if anybody has ever had their foot
stepped on irregardless if it's just a
little hero heel or not you know that it
hurts your toes right it's a lot of
pressure it's a lot of pressure on your
on your feet so this actually this
amount of mass and this amount of area
or this amount of force per area which
is what pressure is would only
correspond about half a Giga Pascal half
a GPA half a GPA that's about five
thousand times the pressure that you're
feeling on your ears right now okay so
it's less than then what I can do in my
diamond cell by me just standing on it
so it would actually take about 700 of
these elephants stacked on top of each
other in a stiletto heel to produce the
kinds of pressures that I can in the
diamond cell for it to produce all the
pressures in the earth okay and that's
because the area of that diamond that
I'm looking at is about the size of my
hair the thickness of my hair that's how
small it is okay I have these diamonds
they're not actually real diamonds but
just this just a show right you put your
you put your sample in between there and
then you can press it question so if I
put an elephant on top of this hmm let's
see so I'm about how do it so an
elephant is about five thousand
kilometers I'm roughly and I'm rounding
these numbers 50 kilograms okay so five
thousand versus fifty right so we have a
factor of a hundred their difference
okay so if I put one elephant on on my
diamond cell and let it and let it do
its thing then it would produce a
thousand Giga Pascal which is much much
much higher pressures than in the earth
so when the earth we have about 350 Giga
Pascal's yeah so so if I had an elephant
in my lab I could put him on my diamond
cell it probably be really messy but but
uh but you could do that yeah good
question okay so that gives us pressure
but how do we get the temperatures after
all their Earth is hot inside okay the
the highest temperature is probably in
the in the core of the planet is
probably something of upwards of 6,000
Kelvin okay so it's really hot so what
we can do is we can actually shine a
laser onto our sample sitting between
those two diamonds and heat it up
and we can heat it up to thousands of
degrees so temperature is not an issue
but I'm so so actually so since I've
already given you a little bit of flavor
of what of what these pressures mean I
want to go a little bit further than
that because it just to kind of catch
you guys up so our ears are very
sensitive to pressure okay when you if
you've gone up into an airplane right
you have to like clear your ears because
your ears can feel that pressure change
as you've gone up into the atmosphere
the pressure actually decreases when
you're at elevation even if you just
drive up to a mountain if anyone goes
skiing or so forth they drive up through
the mountain you'll have to change you
know you have to click your ears because
your your the pressure on your ears have
changed or when you've dived down deep
into the deep end of the pool you can
fear the pressure increase on your ears
okay so our practice our ears are quite
sensitive okay so the pressure around 15
pounds per square inch for those of you
who think in psi1 atmosphere is about 1
bar okay that's the pressure we're
feeling here since we're basically at
sea level but then if we just go didn't
dive down to the deep part of the pool
okay so we're not very deep into the
pool the pressure has already increased
by 30% so and why is it increased by 30%
why has the pressure increase when we go
down into the deep end of the pool
because water is denser than air right
so all that mass of that water is now
pushing up against your ears okay and
and and water is definitely denser than
air so it doesn't take very much to to
increase the increase the pressure now
rock is also more dense than water and
iron is even denser still so that's why
as we go deep down into the planet the
pressures get higher and higher now if
we were to go down to the deepest parts
of the ocean so in the Pacific the
bottom of the Mariana Trench which is at
a depth of about 10 kilometers that
corresponds to about 1,000 times the
pressure you're feeling on your ears and
then if we could go all the way to the
center of the planet its 3.6 million
times the pressure on your ears okay so
these are incredible pressures so this
is how the pressures increase so
basically zero and then we increase
increase increase in pressure and we
increase increase increase in
temperature really really hot okay so
when it's hot though how do you lose
this heat how do we transport this heat
that becomes the next part of this
puzzle how do we transport this heat so
we're all very familiar with how how we
actually can transport this heat okay
and in the earth and the deep part of
the earth the main form of heat
transport is through convection and what
that means and what's us shown here is
hot stuff Rises because it expands and
then as it rises it can cool but as it
cools it contracts and becomes more
dense so as it comes more dense than it
drops down but when it drops down it
hits something that's hot and it expands
and their fur gets less dense and Rises
but it cools and then density
and then drops down and so you have this
cycle this conduction cycle okay we can
see this in a teapot
all right oh and I even had something
going on here that it wasn't paying
attention to Oh unfortunately I think
it's not hot enough um anyway maybe for
those who are interested we can look at
it later this happens in in water this
happens also in air this is what this is
what you you might feel it as we were in
wintertime here right heat rises and
cold air hot air rises and cold air
drops sinks so this kind of mechanism is
also going on in the earth but at a much
larger scale this is how we get mixing
of the mantle and this is actually how
we get mixing in the in the core okay so
let's look here in the mantle so hot
things are rising uh-huh but then cold
things like oceanic slabs that are say
sinking underneath Japan for instance
are sinking but then they come back down
here and it's hot it's hotter down here
than it is up there and so they might
rise again okay and so you get this
motion this convective motion that is
mixing up the inside of the planet and
when it's mixing up the inside of the
planet well that's got to do stuff to
the top right it's got to affect the
surface and in fact it does so here's a
map of all of the major plates that are
part of this plate tectonics okay so we
have this large Pacific plate here where
the Ring of Fire is around and the
arrows here show the motion of where
those plates are going and this motion
so on this side of the plate it's
actually going down but on this side of
the plate here it's actually spreading
okay so new land is formed here with
volcanism but it's being destroyed or
being subducted on the other side so you
have parts where you have magma would be
coming up on this side and then plates
are going down on this side like we saw
on the other so that we're seeing an
expression of all these of the plate
motion here is occurring because of the
convective motions underneath and that's
what's giving us all of our volcanoes
and our earthquakes and they line up
very nicely on those plate boundaries so
if you missed that little show it again
so we have the plate boundaries here and
I try to line them up with the
earthquakes you can basically draw the
same map just by drawing the outlines of
those earthquakes so I'm gonna end and
say like this is what we've been able to
do we've been able to take seismology
mineral physics petrology and
geochemistry as well as geo dynamics or
this convective motion and describe
what's going on on the inside to then
tell us or inform us about what is on
the outside and so I'll end there and
I'll take any questions
yes uh-huh
oh those are those are very
comparatively quite shallow oh yeah yeah
much I'm tens of metres I mean not not
deep at all yeah they're dirty
yeah kind of I think I should have
turned it up a little higher so what was
shown on the video here we have some
corn syrup that I'm heating from the
bottom and and so on the bottom here is
hot and on the top is is relatively cold
and so you'll see little bubbles that
are rising right it's you feel hopefully
you can see it if I had if I had been
paying attention I would have it may be
too warm altogether but what we if you
if you do this properly what you'll be
able to see is you'll start to see these
plumes of hot material coming up like we
think is going on in the mantle okay so
we can we can model that with some corn
syrup yeah question
oh yeah there it's those um those are
all underwater volcanoes they're called
mid-ocean ridges and let's see if I can
so so so actually so so these volcanoes
here are the ones you can see on the
surface but where all these red parts
are where they're just say they're
earthquakes that's that's a mid-ocean
ridge that is defined by by volcanism
yeah but but deep under the water so you
don't you don't see it but they've taken
samples and so forth I mean this the
does anybody know how fast this is
happening that's something we haven't
talked about like how fast things are
moving on the surface you know that's
about right yeah that's about right okay
so we're talking about millimeters to
centimeters depending on where you are
on the planet millimeters to centimeters
per year okay it's about as fast as your
fingernails grow okay that these plates
are spreading apart okay that the plates
are spreading apart and then being taken
up by their subduction on the other side
so yeah everyone's looking at their
fingernails like I cut my fingernails
about once a week maybe my toes go a
little faster than others but but that's
how fast these things move okay so this
the convection underneath is moving at
those scales okay so even though it
seems rather slow it's something that we
can measure and obviously and we could
feel if it for those of you who felt
earthquakes yes
no I don't know what you mean by that
California is moving laterally so
there's a so lots of earthquakes you
know along along the west coast okay
that's because the Pacific plate is
moving with respect to the North
American plate so they're moving like
this but not underneath right so if this
if this one would have worked like I
wanted it to so it's so we think that
the the hot spot that is feeding the
Hawaii Volcanoes actually comes down
from the core-mantle boundary so almost
3,000 kilometers depth okay where it's
really hot oh here we go
is it going down oh yeah here that's
right so you have bubbles coming up here
that's hot and then you have other stuff
that's coming down so this is stuff that
already went to the top got cold and
came down so imagine now if Hawaii as a
hot spot so that material
okay would be coming from this depth now
it wouldn't be molten at this it would
just be hotter than everything else
would be buoyant but not molten it
doesn't actually melt to gets to the
surface but it's it's it's it's rising
because it's really hot down near the
core so like 4,000 degrees and by the
time but it's solid but it's solid yeah
yeah that's what it appears to be
because yeah it's why is it stable maybe
that this is this is a hugely I mean
this is under active but the plane moves
across so I don't have a good map but
for those
you who don't know so Hawaii has many
many islands there are 132 islands that
make up the Hawaiian chain and where the
active volcania volcania MS is at the
most southeastern part of it
so here but it stretches up past here
that's right of this angle and then
there's actually a kink in it that goes
a little more north and so that kink and
and then they can date how you know when
these things would have occurred that
kink then represents probably a change
in the entire plate motion so the plate
is moving over this what appears to be
fixed hot spot and I mean that's the the
best sort of hypothesis at this point
given the data that we that'swhy you
have a change of islands yeah a new
island pops up yeah so the plate moves
and then this this this magma just
coming up and as the plate moves it just
pops up new new islands
hmm oh you mean the here come on right
here yes all the time actually and so so
the last so these things are called
super consonants and the last
supercontinent was called Pangaea and
about 200 million years ago you can
actually kind of fit the pieces together
so like this part of Africa here would
have kind of fit South America here and
this part here would have fit over here
this part here onto Europe and the whole
part the whole all the contents you can
imagine now we're part of one large
supercontinent that broke up about 200
million years ago with this Ridge which
is called the mid-atlantic ridge so this
Ridge here is spreading those continents
apart so that is happening now here in
this ridge system - that is that appears
to be happening - you have some you have
some ridge action going on here so some
splitting now again this takes a really
long time but it is at least there's
evidence for several of these super
continents over the last billion to two
billion years yes
exactly yeah and then we can compare
that to the rate that is being currently
measured today and it's pretty it's
pretty constant at least for the last
200 million years yeah oh that's a good
question
um-hmm okay so for those of you so let's
illicit background so the question was
on on earthquakes that have been induced
by fracking in Oklahoma so Oklahoma
Corrine so okay we all know California's
got lots of earthquakes right that's
pretty that's pretty common actually
Oklahoma today has more earthquakes than
California does okay which this was not
true 10 years ago and the and the
thought is that the so when you frakking
is a is a kind of way that you can
extract natural gas or oil from the
rocks okay and you use water to
basically fracture the rocks and pull
out that natural gas they use the water
to pull out the natural gas but then
this water ends up being kind of yucky
and dirty so that afterwards after they
have this water it's not a good idea to
then put it into the rivers or lakes cuz
it will destroy the drinking water so
they put it back into the into the rock
this increases the pressure on the rock
which then if you're increasing the
pressure on something think of this is
different kind of pressure but think of
when you're trying to boil a pot of
water on your stove right and you put a
lid on top of it and as it starts to
boil right that gas pressure of the of
the water being vaporized as it's being
boiled starts to pop up okay so this so
this kind of pressure a different kind
of pressure but this kind of pressure is
going to is going to stress the rock
okay and it's the stressing that's
causing the earthquakes now his question
now was will that water than a
you know could that water then make the
rocks melt and then produce volcanoes
so you still wouldn't need the rock to
be hot in order to get melting it would
be have to be hot enough for that for
any of that water that it would then
sort of affect the the surrounding rock
to sort of join into it and then weaken
it so that it would melt my my my
initial gut would say no because it's
because it's not generally hot in that
part because it's part of a consonant
consonant Rock kind of constants or
rocks on average are colder cuz they're
older so I don't think it would be hot
enough but in but I get where you're
going in terms of the principles of like
adding water to the system it should
lower the melting temperature it just
may not be hot enough still
in Oklahoma it has I so the the kinds of
history that we have I mean so in terms
of seismometer history you know we've
got decades worth of data and but we
also have written data and written you
know historical logs on when large
earthquakes and so forth have happened
over you know hundreds of years or even
thousands of years where when people
were taking you know if you just read
sort of the history so you know has it
increased or decrease or the the
seismometers have become more sensitive
so we can you know we can measure them
but you know do we have any reason to
believe that as a whole that the earth
is doing something different than it did
you know a thousand years ago no there's
no evidence for that
well locally because of stuff like
fracking yes in that region there are
definitely more earthquakes and there
were ever at least in the in the recent
past so a how are we doing for timing
over okay we have questions stay
afterwards but let's thankfully
[Applause]
[Music]